well I think you can really trace it
back to at least the 1960s if not
earlier what we started to see going on
in American politics in the 1960s and
continuing into the 70s and 80s was
really the disintegration of the old New
Deal coalition and alignment that had
been kind of put together by Franklin
Roosevelt and that sustained the
Democratic Party as the dominant party
in American politics for many years that
coalition consisted of a number of
groups such as white Southerners
northern white ethnic voters and white
working-class voters that inherently had
little in common with each other
particularly when you add in the growing
representation of african-american
voters after the 1960s with the Voting
Rights Act so this coalition was sort of
inherently unstable and what we began to
see in the 1960s especially after the
passage of the Voting Rights Act and the
growth of the african-american
electorate was that the more
conservative elements in that coalition
particularly white Southerners but also
conservative white ethnic voters began
to move toward the Republicans we had an
ideological realignment that began
didn't happen overnight it was it was
not something that occurred in a single
election or a couple of elections it was
something that took place over several
decades actually but we gradually began
to see these more conservative voters
moving away from the Democrats and into
the Republican camp and on the other
hand in response to that more moderate
to liberal voters who had been aligned
with the Republicans especially in parts
of the country where you had moderate to
liberal Republicans like the Northeast
they began to
move away from the Republicans and
toward the Democrats as the Republican
Party became increasingly conservative
so you can see this beginning with
Richard Nixon's Southern Strategy in
1972 and continuing with Ronald Reagan's
presidential campaigns and then
certainly in the 1990s with the takeover
of the Republican Party in Congress by a
more conservative group of leaders led
by Newt Gingrich so essentially what was
happening here was that at the elite
level we were seeing an increasing
ideological polarization and that change
began to affect the loyalties of the
voters and increasingly over time and by
the time we got to the 1990s it had
reached the point where the old
Democratic coalition and the Democratic
dominance of at least Congress was no
longer no longer existed and it's really
continued even up to the present time
now something else that's been happening
over this entire time period and
especially the last couple of decades
it's also playing into this has been the
demographic changes taking place in the
electorate and the growing diversity of
the American electorate where non-white
voters are becoming a larger and largest
share of the electorate and particularly
of the Democratic coalition so that by
2008 when you look at the contributions
of different racial and ethnic groups to
the party coalition's you see that
non-whites made up over 40% of
Democratic voters whereas non-whites
were only about 7 or 8 percent of
Republican voters you know so this is
growing divergence between the parties
both in terms of the racial and ethnic
groups that support the parties and also
in terms of ideology and issues
it's the more engaged segments of the
public that really becomes increasingly
polarized because they're the ones who
are really following these debates who
are really attentive to what is going on
in the Congress to the positions of the
parties and so they tend to react much
more quickly than people who are just
not you know not paying attention but
what happens over time is that even
though this process of realignment
really was I think initiated by
political elites for strategic reasons
so you had Republican politicians in
particular who I think saw opportunities
to win over some of these voting groups
that had been traditionally supporting
the Democrats but once the public or at
least the attentive segment of the
public becomes polarized that in turn
sort of starts to constrain the
positions of political elites themselves
and now they have to reflect the views
of the voters who make up their their
own base and so what we're seeing today
is that it's gotten to the point where
the party leaders and candidates for
office are really kind of constrained to
a large degree by the polarization that
exists among the attentive public so if
you look for example of primary voters
you find that you know Republican
primary voters are really quite
conservative by a large Democratic
primary voters tend to be fairly liberal
and therefore candidates who want to be
successful in politics you know have to
appeal to these primary voters in
addition there are more and more
congressional districts and even states
where one party is dominant and
therefore the key to success in those
types of districts in those types of
states is again just to appeal to the
party base and there's less need to
worry about appealing to voters from the
other party so political campaigns have
become more about mobilizing the base
than about appealing to the
swing voters in the middle